THANK YOU FOR THAT ABLE
DESCRIPTION.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHEN THE 2020 RACE STARTED,
JOE BIDEN LOOKED LIKE A VERY
SAFE PICK.
AND HE WAS THE CONSENSUS PICK.
NOW IT'S NOT AS CLEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORTS THOUGH
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN IS
CONSIDERING A NEW AND BOLD
STRATEGY.
WHAT IF BIDEN PROMISED TO SERVE
ONLY ONE TERM IF ELECTED?
WHAT THAT WORK?
OR WOULD IT SERVE ONLY TO
EMPHASIZE HIS ADVANCED AGE.
HERE'S THE HOST OF DAILY
BRIEFING.
JOE BIDEN'S YOUNGER ACTUALLY
THAN BERNIE SANDERS.
SO FOR HIM TO SAY I WILL SERVE
ONLY ONE TERM, APPEARS TO BE
CONCEDING.
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
WHERE IT'S ALL COMING FROM.
APPARENTLY THERE IS A DEBATE
AMONGST FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S TOP ADVISORS, THE
PROMINENT CONSULTANTS, AND THEY
ARE THROWING THIS OUT THERE.
THEY ARE SAYING WHAT DO PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT THIS?
AND THAT EMPHASIZES THE
WEAKNESSES.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND, SOME
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WHAT AMERICANS
WANT AS AN END TO THE CHAOS.
AND I HAVE A FEW BIG PROBLEMS
WITH THE IDEA OF RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND SAYING YOU ARE
ONLY GOING TO RUN FOR ONE TERM.
AND HOW COULD YOU REBUILD THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
WITH A LAME DUCK PRESIDENT ON
HIS FIRST DAY AND YOU WILL HAVE
A PRIMARY THAT COULD CONTINUE.
IMAGINE A FIVE YEAR
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE CONSULTANTS WOULD MAKE SO
MUCH MONEY.
OF COURSE, I'M NOT GOING TO DO
THAT BUT, IT'S AN ISSUE.
AND IT ALSO MAKES HIM SEEM LIKE
HE'S NOT UP FOR THE JOB.
THEN JUST BE THE STOPGAP MEASURE
UNTIL THE DEMOCRATIC SAVIOR CAN
EMERGE.
>> AND THAT COULD BE THE EFFECT
FOR THE NOMINEE THREE YEARS FROM
NOW.
>> THAT'S LIKE WHO WOULD BE
BEST.
THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY
SAYS MAY BE STACY OF GEORGIA,
BECAUSE SHE WON THE GOVERNOR'S
ELECTION.
SO LET'S SAY THAT HE PICKS STACY
ABRAM.
IMMEDIATELY SHE THINKS THAT
SHE'S A FRONT RUNNER TO RUN IN
2024 BECAUSE WHY WOULD SHE THINK
THAT?
THEY WOULD BE SURROUNDED BY
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO TAKE HER OUT.
>> SO YOU JUST EXPLAINED IN
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF MINUTES WHY
THIS IS THE WORST IDEA ANYONE
HAS EVER COME UP WITH.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF EVER BUT,
THEY THROW THE STUFF OUT THERE
AND, JOE BIDEN IS STILL DOING
VERY WELL NATIONALLY IN THE
POLLS.
>> AMAZING.
YOU PREDICTED FROM THE BEGINNING
THAT HE WILL BE THE NOMINEE.
>> DID I PREDICT THAT?
>> Tucker: I'M PUTTING WORDS